This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All right, and next up we have Diana shouting out to the Polonski unit. Um, Hito, it's Mamadi. I know it sounds kind of different. I'm very sick right now. I've diagnosed pneumonia, I've been sick already for quite some time now. This is the voice of a woman calling into a radio show on the Texas Station KPFA. She has a personal message for a prison in me.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。好的，接下来由戴安娜向波伦斯基小队大声喊话。呃，希托，我是马马迪。我知道听起来有点不一样。我现在病得很重。我被诊断出患有肺炎，我已经病了相当长一段时间了。这是一个女人打电话给德克萨斯州KPFA电台一个节目的声音。她要给一个监狱里的囚犯传达一条私人信息。
Anyway, I want to tell you that Mama delves you. I always think of you and of... It's just getting harder and harder. I know I'm not the most surprised you're gonna get mad at me, but I can't help but feel so much love for you. Calling into a program like this is one of the few ways for spouses and parents and children to communicate with prisoners, especially inmates and solitary confinement.
总之，我想告诉你，马马很爱你。我总是想起你和……事情变得越来越难了。我知道我不是最让你吃惊的人，你可能会生我的气，但我忍不住对你满怀爱意。打进这样的节目，是配偶、父母和孩子与囚犯交流的少数几种方式之一，特别是对那些处于单人禁闭中的囚犯而言。
Many prisoners in solitary have been found guilty of heinous crimes, including murder, rape, terrorism, but here's something you might not know. Some are there because they're difficult to manage or because of bureaucratic inertia. While judges and juries decide whether someone should go to prison, a decision that can be appealed in court, typically its prison officials who decide whether someone should be in solitary confinement. In recent years, both liberals and conservatives worried about the psychological and financial costs of long-term solitary confinement have raised questions about the practice. This week on Hidden Brain, we thought we'd take a look at what happens inside the prison
许多处于单人禁闭中的囚犯被裁定犯有令人发指的罪行，包括谋杀、强奸、恐怖主义，但有一点你可能不知道。有些人被关在那里是因为他们很难管理，或者由于官僚机构的惯性。虽然法官和陪审团决定某人是否应该入狱（这是一个可以在法庭上上诉的决定），但通常是监狱官员决定某人是否应该被关进单人禁闭室。近年来，担心长期单人禁闭带来的心理和经济成本的自由派和保守派都对这种做法提出了质疑。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们想带大家一探究竟，看看监狱内部发生了什么——
cells that few people ever see and the psychological effects of being alone for long periods of time. Caramet Rider is a professor of criminology at the University of California Irvine, and the author of the new book, 23-7, Pelican Bay Prison, and the rise of long-term solitary confinement. Besides being a researcher, she's also been a prisoner's rights activist at Human Rights Watch. Karamit, welcome to Hidden Brain.
那是很少有人能见到的牢房，以及长期独自一人的心理影响。卡拉米特·赖特是加州大学尔湾分校的犯罪学教授，也是新书《23-7：鹈鹕湾监狱与长期单人禁闭的兴起》的作者。除了作为一名研究人员，她还曾是“人权观察”组织中囚犯权利的活动人士。卡拉米特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me, Shankar. You can't tell the story of solitary confinement without understanding the story of a man named George Jackson. He was sent to prison in the early 1960s after pleading guilty to armed robbery, and he was sentenced to a term of one year to life. What was the thinking behind this kind of indeterminate sentence? So the idea for someone like George Jackson was that he would go to prison and he'd have to prove that he'd been rehabilitated before he could get out of prison. Around the time Jackson went to prison, however, people started to look at these indeterminate sentences
谢谢邀请我，香卡。如果不了解乔治·杰克逊这个人的故事，你就无法讲述单人禁闭的故事。他在20世纪60年代初因承认武装抢劫而被送进监狱，并被判处一年至无期徒刑。这种不定期刑期背后的想法是什么？所以，对乔治·杰克逊这样的人的想法是，他进入监狱后，必须证明自己已经改过自新，然后才能离开监狱。然而，在大约杰克逊入狱的时期，人们开始审视这些不定期刑期——
and realize that they were having truly disproportionate impacts depending on the race of the person with the sentence. So white people had a much easier time convincing prison officials that they had been reformed and should be let out at prison than African-American men like George Jackson happened to be. So George Jackson found himself essentially stuck in prison, years went by when he was denied parole, and he became radicalized in this process.
并意识到它们产生了真正不成比例的影响，这取决于受刑者的种族。因此，白人要让监狱官员相信他们已经改过自新并应该被释放，比乔治·杰克逊这样的非裔美国人要容易得多。因此，乔治·杰克逊发现自己基本上被困在监狱里，多年过去了，他的假释申请一直被拒绝，在这个过程中，他变得激进化了。
He wrote a book of best-selling letters that achieved national and international acclaim, letters to his family and to his lawyers, articulating his revolutionary politics and the problems with things like this indeterminate sentence. This brought him to the attention of prison officials, and he was accused of murdering a prison guard in the early 1970s, and he was preemptively sent to death row at San Quentin while he awaited a death penalty trial for that murder he was accused of.
他写了一本畅销书信集，在国内外获得了高度赞誉——写给家人和律师的信，表达了他的革命政治观点以及像这种不定期刑期之类的问题所带来的弊端。这引起了监狱官员的注意，在20世纪70年代初，他被指控谋杀了一名狱警，在等待该谋杀指控的死刑审判期间，他被先发制人地送到了圣昆廷监狱的死囚牢房。
And while on death row at San Quentin in an isolation unit, interestingly, one day his lawyer came in to visit him. And the story that prison officials tell and that's been repeated many times is that his lawyer snuck a nine millimeter gun into him inside of a tape recorder. And that Jackson then used that gun to try to escape from this isolation unit. All we actually know is that he was shot to death on the San Quentin prison yard as he ran out of the isolation unit. And when staff ran into the unit to see what had happened, they found three officers and two more prisoners who'd been stabbed to death.
而在圣昆廷监狱隔离区的死囚牢房里，有趣的是，有一天他的律师来看望他。监狱官员讲述并被多次重复的故事是，他的律师把一把九毫米手枪藏在录音机里带给了他。然后杰克逊用那把枪试图逃离这个隔离区。我们实际知道的全部是，当他跑出隔离区时，他在圣昆廷监狱的院子里被枪杀。当工作人员冲进牢房查看发生了什么时，他们发现三名警官和另外两名囚犯被刺身亡。
So this was the most violent day in California's prison history ever. Six deaths total on August 21st, 1971. And this moment is a moment that people point to, in California, as incredibly important in understanding why the state needed long-term solitary confinement units. And similar things happened across the US, and prison officials in other states point to those moments.
所以这是加州监狱史上最暴力的一天。1971年8月21日，总共有六人死亡。人们指出，在加州，这一时刻对于理解为什么该州需要长期单人禁闭室具有极其重要的意义。美国各地也发生了类似的事情，其他州的监狱官员也指出过这些时刻。
So two weeks after George Jackson died, the revolted Attica happened. Similarly, following that, prisoners were locked into their cells, and that became a moment people pointed to as a justification for really long-term solitary confinement. You also tell the story of a prison administrator,
因此，在乔治·杰克逊死后两周，阿提卡监狱暴动发生了。同样，在那之后，囚犯们被锁在牢房里，这成为了人们认为可以证明真正长期的单人禁闭是正当的理由的一个时刻。你还讲述了一位监狱管理人员的故事——
Carl Larson, who began his career the same year that George Jackson went to prison. I understand you interviewed Carl Larson and his view gives us a glimpse into the other side of the story how prison guards and prison officials see the need for solitary confinement. So Carl Larson was one of the earlier people I interviewed in doing this work and to my surprise we got to be friends. I came at this work from a from a perspective of a prisoner's rights advocate, very critical of the system. But as I got to know Carl Larson, I saw that he had a really interesting perspective on the system. And he was one of the first people to point me to the story of George Jackson and to explain
卡尔·拉尔森，他在乔治·杰克逊入狱的同一年开始了他的职业生涯。据我所了解，你采访了卡尔·拉尔森，他的观点让我们得以一窥故事的另一面，即狱警和监狱官员如何看待单人禁闭的必要性。卡尔·拉尔森是我做这项工作时较早采访的人之一，令我惊讶的是，我们成了朋友。我做这项工作时带着囚犯权利倡导者的视角，对这个体制非常批判。但随着我对卡尔·拉尔森的了解，我发现他对这个体制有着非常有趣的看法。他是最早向我指出乔治·杰克逊故事的人之一，并向我解释了——
how scary it was to be a guard working in the California prisons in the 1970s when these deaths were happening. And to make that fear real for me in a way that helped me to understand why he thought a long-term solitary confinement facility made sense. So Carl Larson is particularly interesting because, as you said, he started out as an officer in the 1970s in California prisons, actually even earlier. And then he worked his way up through the system, becoming a warden, and then becoming head of the prison construction projects that California engaged in in the 1980s,
在20世纪70年代这些命案发生时，在加州监狱工作的狱警是多么令人恐惧。他让这种恐惧对我来说变得真实，这有助于我理解为什么他认为长期的单人禁闭设施是有意义的。因此，卡尔·拉尔森特别有趣，因为正如你所说，他最初是20世纪70年代加州监狱的一名警官，甚至更早。然后他在体制内步步高升，成为了一名监狱长，接着又成为了加州在20世纪80年代参与的监狱建设项目的负责人。
when the state built one of these long-term, solitary confinement supermax facilities. And he takes credit for designing one of the first of these institutions, and that's really interesting, because he's a prison administrator. He's not an architect. He's not an expert in exactly what kinds of punishments work. He didn't have a law degree.
当时该州建造了这些长期单人禁闭超级最高安全级别设施之一。他把设计这些机构之一归功于自己，这真的很有趣，因为他是一名监狱管理者。他不是建筑师。他不是关于哪种惩罚真正有效的专家。他没有法律学位。
He had just worked in prisons and he designed this completely new facility. I understand that there was some interesting architectural features of this facility, Pelican Bay. The cement for the facility was poured in one large block, and so that the cells were not built in individual units? Mm-hmm. So, one of the things that's striking about the places it's made of these poured concrete cells, so they're incredibly easy to hose down, which is the fact that they can stay clean is important because quartz earlier had criticized isolation units for being
他只是在监狱工作过，就设计了这个全新的设施。据我了解，这个设施——鹈鹕湾监狱——有一些有趣的建筑特点。该设施的水泥是一大块浇筑的，所以牢房不是建在单个的单元里的？嗯哼。所以，关于这个地方引人注目的一点是，它是用这些浇筑的混凝土牢房组成的，所以它们极其容易用水管冲洗保持清洁，这一点很重要，因为科茨早些时候曾批评隔离区——
really dirty. And they're grouped together into these pods of eight, and then the pods of eight are grouped together again into these tessulated T structures, so that one officer can look out over six pods of cells at a time. So it's a modern panopticon, and that also, that allows the fact that there are no windows makes it really easy to just fit all these blocks together
真的很脏。它们被组合成这些八个一组的舱，然后八个一组的舱再次组合成这些密铺的T形结构，这样一名警官可以同时俯瞰六个牢房舱。所以这是一个现代全景监狱，而且这也使得没有窗户这一事实变得很容易，只需将所有这些区块组合在一起——
if you can imagine that structure. I'm wondering, Kermad, if you can actually just describe what one of these cells looks like. Give me a sense of what's in the cell, how big it is. What does it actually feel like to be in one of these units? So the cells in these units are generally about 8 by 10 feet. So imagine a wheelchair accessible bathroom stall or a generous parking space. Pretty small. You can almost reach from one end of the cell to the other. And they're fairly self-contained. So they contain a poured concrete ledge with a very thin piece of foam over it, and that's
如果你能想象那种结构的话。卡拉米特，我想知道你是否能具体描述一下其中一个牢房是什么样子的。让我对牢房里的东西以及它有多大有个概念。身处其中一个单元究竟是什么感觉？这些单元里的牢房通常大约是8乘10英尺。所以想象一下无障碍卫生间的隔间，或者一个宽敞的停车位。相当小。你几乎可以从牢房的一端够到另一端。而且它们相当自给自足。所以它们包含一个浇筑的混凝土矮台，上面铺着一张非常薄的海绵垫，那就是——
the bed. And then there's another concrete bit protruding that is a desk and seat combination. So it's just like a concrete block that a prisoner could sit on and write there. And then there's in another corner, there's a steel usually toilet sink combination. So it's just one smooth steel object that has running water and plumbing for the prisoner. Sometimes there are showers in these cells, but generally it's just a sink and a toilet. And again, if the prisoner is lucky, and they can afford it, and the system therein allows that they might have a TV or a radio.
床。然后还有另一个突出的混凝土部分，它是书桌和座椅的组合。所以它就像一个混凝土块，囚犯可以坐在上面并在那里写字。然后在另一个角落，通常有一个钢制的马桶和水槽组合。所以它只是一个光滑的钢制物件，有供囚犯使用的自来水和管道。有时这些牢房里有淋浴间，但通常只有一个水槽和一个马桶。同样，如果囚犯很幸运，他们付得起钱，并且那里的制度允许的话，他们可能会有一台电视或收音机。
And usually they're allowed maybe a few books at a time, and a little bit of paper for writing letters or doing legal paperwork. You say in the book that despite what prison officials say, it's not always the worst of the worst who end up in solitary confinement, but in general, are there patterns to predict who ends up in solitary confinement? There's been shockingly little research over time on who ends up in solitary confinement and how, and it's very hard to track across states. But as people have paid more attention to this,
通常他们一次可以被允许看几本书，以及一点用于写信或处理法律文件的纸。你在书中提到，尽管监狱官员这么说，但最终被关进单人禁闭室的不一定总是“最坏中的最坏”，但总的来说，有没有什么规律可以预测谁最终会进单人禁闭室？令人震惊的是，随着时间的推移，关于谁最终会进入单人禁闭室以及如何进入的研究少之又少，而且很难在各州之间进行追踪。但随着人们对此给予更多关注——
and through the work I've done, I've started to see some patterns. There's a disproportionate racial impact of solitary confinement, so we know that in our prisons in general, African Americans and Latinos are more likely to be in prison than in the general prison population. They're doubly likely, again, to be in solitary confinement than in the general prison population, they're doubly likely again to be in solitary confinement than even the general prison population. That's often because gang members are being targeted
通过我所做的工作，我开始看到一些规律。单人禁闭存在不成比例的种族影响，所以我们知道，在我们的监狱里，非裔美国人和拉丁裔比在普通监狱人口中更有可能入狱。他们在单人禁闭室里的可能性又翻了一番，与普通监狱人口相比，他们在单人禁闭室里的可能性甚至比普通监狱人口还要高出一倍。这通常是因为帮派成员被针对——
for long-term isolation, especially in states like California, prison systems are not putting people there based on some act or rule that they broke, but based on their status as dangerous. So prisoners get labeled dangerous gang members and they get sent to isolation indefinitely. In general, I think one way to think about people who end up in isolation is that it's often the people who are really difficult for the system to manage, so that might include
进行长期隔离，特别是在像加州这样的州，监狱系统把人关进去不是基于他们打破了什么行为或规则，而是基于他们作为危险分子的身份。因此，囚犯被贴上危险帮派成员的标签，并被无限期地送往隔离区。总的来说，我认为思考那些最终进入隔离区的人的一种方式是，他们通常是系统很难管理的人，所以这可能包括——
seriously mentally ill prisoners. There's recent research showing that transgender prisoners are really likely to end up in isolation, that pregnant women end up there. So people who the system just isn't equipped to provide resources to can end up there also. So the rise of these institutions coincided in some ways with decline or closing down of various institutions for the mentally ill, which speaks, of course, to the point that you are just making. But I also understand that this is reflected in the number of suicides we see in solitary confinement compared to the general prison population. There is a very close relationship between solitary confinement and mental illness. One way to understand that is that in the 1970s and early 80s, when mental institutions closed, was the same time that mass incarceration and
患有严重精神疾病的囚犯。最近的研究表明，跨性别囚犯极有可能最终进入隔离区，孕妇也会去那里。因此，系统没有配备资源来为其提供帮助的人最终也可能会去那里。因此，这些机构的兴起在某些方面与精神病患者各种机构的衰落或关闭同时发生，这当然印证了你刚才所说的观点。但我也明白，这体现在与普通监狱人口相比，我们在单人禁闭室中看到的自杀人数上。单人禁闭与精神疾病之间存在着非常紧密的联系。理解这一点的一种方式是，在20世纪70年代和80年代初，当精神病院关闭时，正是全美大规模监禁和监禁率不断上升的时期。
rates of incarceration were increasing across the United States. And that meant that some mentally ill people unsurprisingly ended up in prisons, and one of the arguments I make is that as those people ended up in prison, they tended to be put into solitary confinement. And that's one explanation for the fact that rates of suicide and solitary confinement can be twice as high as in the general prison population or even higher, and that rates of mental illness and isolation can be high. And often there's a real chicken and egg problem of, you know, did a person get sent isolation
这意味着一些精神病患者毫不意外地最终进入了监狱，我提出的观点之一是，当这些人进入监狱时，他们往往会被关进单人禁闭室。这是对以下事实的一种解释：单人禁闭室的自杀率可以是普通监狱人口的两倍甚至更高，而且隔离室中的精神疾病发病率也很高。通常这里面存在一个真正的先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，你知道的，一个人被送进隔离区是因为他们患有精神疾病，而各州试图限制这一点，还是隔离区的人患上了精神疾病？我们大多数人永远不会看到超级最高安全级别监狱的内部，但我们经常在流行文化中看到被描述的单人禁闭场景。其中一个例子就是电视剧《女子监狱》。我们有一段录音。角色派珀被关进安全住房单元——
because they were mentally ill and states have tried to limit that or do people in isolation developmental illnesses? Most of us are never going to see the inside of a supermax, but we often do see scenes of solitary confinement described in pop culture. One of those examples is the TV show Orange is the New Black. We have a bit of tape. The character Piper is put into a security housing unit
并开始和一个声音说话。她通过牢房的格栅听到了这个声音。你在这里多久了？我记不清了。我知道。
and starts speaking to a voice. She hears through the grate of her cell. How long have you been down here? I lost track. I know. speaking to a voice, she hears through the grade of herself. That's insane. I keep the lights on. See, it was all sensitive. It's not living. I mean, yeah, you're breathing. You're taking up the personal more. It's bad. Start to see shit that ain't there.
和她通过牢房格栅听到的声音说话。这太疯狂了。我一直开着灯。看，这很敏感。这不是活着。我是说，是的，你在呼吸。你占据了更多的人。这很糟糕。开始看到不存在的鬼东西。
Start to hear voices. Oh, my God. Keep you here until they break. I feel like I'm going to throw up. Karamit, I'm wondering how accurate that description is of what lives actually like in solitary confinement. I do think that the disembodied voice that you hear talking to Piper is accurate on a number of levels. The voice is kind of flattened and affect, and the prisoner was describing hearing voices, hallucinations.
开始听到声音。哦，天哪。把你留在这里直到你崩溃。我觉得我要吐了。卡拉米特，我想知道对单人禁闭中真实生活的描述有多准确。我确实认为你听到对派珀说话的那个虚无缥缈的声音在多个层面上都是准确的。这个声音听起来很平淡、缺乏情感，而囚犯则在描述听到声音、幻觉。
That's a very common side effect of isolation. And people talk about time, the way they perceive time changing because there is no way to mark time. People talk about it. Exactly as that prisoner said, it's not that it even feels long. It's just that it's almost endless. That days can kind of in a weird counterintuitive way fly by, Exactly as that prisoner said, it's not that it even feels long. It's just that it's almost endless. That days can kind of in a weird counterintuitive way fly by because there's nothing marking
这是隔离非常常见的副作用。人们谈论时间，他们感知时间的方式发生了变化，因为没有办法标记时间。人们谈论它。正如那个囚犯所说，并不是说它感觉有多长。只是它几乎是无止境的。日子可能会以一种奇怪的、反直觉的方式飞逝——
anything about a day or a week. So in that sense, it's accurate. I want to spend a moment talking about your own role in looking at this. On the one hand, you are a researcher who has spent time studying the question, but as you yourself have said, you're also a prison rights advocate. You've been an activist at Human Rights Watch and other organizations. How do you preserve your ability to be analytical about the subject while you also have what are very clearly strong views about solitary confinement?
因为没有任何东西来标记一天或一周的任何事情。所以从这个意义上说，它是准确的。我想花点时间谈谈你自己在审视这个问题时的角色。一方面，你是一个花时间研究这个问题的研究人员，但正如你自己所说，你也是一个监狱权利倡导者。你曾是“人权观察”组织和其他机构的活动人士。在对单人禁闭有着非常明确的强烈观点的同时，你如何保持对这个主题进行分析的能力？
You know, when I went to interview Carl Larson, he said, well, you're a Berkeley liberal. So he asked me to do some background reading and prove that I was serious and I would listen to him. And so I actually think in the process of doing this work, I have become more open-minded. And been criticized by advocates for talking so directly and so extensively to prison officials. And so I've had the interesting experience of trying to keep the conversation open across a really broad spectrum of perspectives on this process.
你知道，当我去采访卡尔·拉尔森时，他说，好吧，你是个伯克利自由派。所以他要求我做一些背景阅读，证明我是认真的，并且我会听他说话。所以我实际上认为在做这项工作的过程中，我变得更加思想开放了。并受到倡导者的批评，因为我和监狱官员进行了如此直接和广泛的对话。所以我有了这样一种有趣的经历，试图在关于这个过程的极其广泛的观点谱系中保持对话的开放。
And I think in that way, I've been able to try to at least incorporate these different perspectives. And tease apart the arguments and the positions people are coming from. And I do think that in reform, prison officials have to walk into these institutions and engage with these prisoners day in and day out, and they also need to be part of the reform conversation. And through this process, surprisingly, even though I came basically from the other side,
我想通过这种方式，我至少能够试图将这些不同的观点融合进来。并剖析人们的论点和立场。而且我确实认为，在改革中，监狱官员必须走进这些机构，日复一日地与这些囚犯接触，他们也需要成为改革对话的一部分。通过这个过程，令人惊讶的是，尽管我基本上来自另一边——
if you want to think of it in terms of sides, I've come to see that perspective. When we come back, I'm going to ask Karamat about the psychological toll of solitary confinement and the unexpected ways in May its managed life in isolation. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Karamit, what sorts of things do people in solitary confinement say they miss? What are the kind of things that you miss that the rest of us might not think about? So people talk about not having seen the moon in years or decades and how much they
如果你想从立场的角度来考虑的话，我已经开始理解那种观点了。当我们回来时，我将询问卡拉米特关于单人禁闭的心理代价，以及它在隔离生活中管理生活的意想不到的方式。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。卡拉米特，身处单人禁闭中的人们说他们最想念什么样的事情？你错过了哪些我们其他人可能不会想到的事情？人们谈论已经几年或几十年没有看到月亮了，以及他们有多么——
miss that. And then people talk about missing just pure human touch. And, you know, I tell a story in the book about a prisoner who, his cell door and the cell door of the prisoner next to him were accidentally opened at the same time, and they were rival gang members. But they had been talking to each other, shouting through the cell walls. And when the cell doors opened, they just reached around
想念那个。然后人们谈论渴望纯粹的人类触碰。而且，你知道，我在书中讲了一个故事，一个囚犯，他的牢房门和紧挨着他的那个囚犯的牢房门不小心同时打开了，他们是敌对帮派的成员。但他们一直在互相交谈，通过牢房墙壁大喊大叫。当牢房门打开时，他们只是把手伸过去——
and grabbed each other's hands and held on, because it had been so long since either of them had had a gentle human touch like that. Prisoners often stay alone in their cells for 22 or 23 hours a day, and you found that, perhaps the only way to actually manage this psychologically is to stick to a series of very, very rigid routines. Tell me about those routines.
抓住彼此的手并紧紧握住，因为他们中无论是谁，都已经太久没有感受到过那样温柔的人类触碰了。囚犯通常一天独自呆在牢房里22或23小时，你发现，也许真正在心理上应对这一情况的唯一方法是坚持一系列非常、非常严格的日常惯例。跟我讲讲这些日常惯例吧。
The prisoners who I was able to interview in this research to understand their experiences tended to be the prisoners who survived. And so they did develop all kinds of coping mechanisms. And one of the ones I heard about again and again was that they would wake up, you know, first thing in the morning, 5 a.m. and they would do thousands of repetitive exercises, often what prisoners call burpees, so a combination of jumping jacks, push-ups and sit-ups, and you know, literally a few thousand in the morning to start out their day, and then clean their cells, write letters, work on legal cases. And in general in these units, if prisoners are following the rules and they have money being sent in from family, they can buy either a TV or a radio.
我在这次研究中能够采访到并了解其经历的囚犯，往往是那些幸存下来的囚犯。因此，他们确实开发了各种应对机制。我一次又一次听到的一种机制是，他们会醒来，你知道的，一大早，早上5点，他们会做成千上万次重复的运动，通常是囚犯们所说的波比跳，也就是开合跳、俯卧撑和仰卧起坐的结合，你知道的，早上 literalmente（字面意思是：字面意义上）做几千个来开始他们的一天，然后打扫牢房，写信，处理法律案件。总的来说，在这些单元里，如果囚犯遵守规则并且有家人汇款进来，他们可以买一台电视或收音机。
And prisoners who develop these routines talk about really limiting the time they spent listening to media. So maybe only an hour a day or two hours a day or a special show they like to watch, so that they were keeping both their bodies and their minds really busy consciously over the course of a day. And interestingly, prisoners talk about having trouble letting go of these routines once they got out of prison,
那些养成这些日常习惯的囚犯谈到，他们真正限制了自己听媒体节目的时间。所以可能一天只听一个小时或两个小时，或者看一个他们喜欢看的特别节目，这样他们在一天当中有意识地让自己的身体和精神都非常忙碌。有趣的是，囚犯们谈到，一旦他们出狱，就很难摆脱这些日常习惯——
that they would still do those thousands of burpees every morning at 5 a.m. when they got up, and that their ability to control everything in their space in that eight by ten cell they live in is also hard to let go of that they could keep, you know, a prisoner described to me how he could keep the cap of his toothpaste perfectly clean and it was really hard when he had a roommate when he got out of prison. The fact that he couldn't control the cap of the toothpaste anymore.
他们每天早上5点起床时仍然会做那几千个波比跳，而且他们在他们生活的那个8乘10英尺的牢房里控制空间里一切的能力也很难放下，他们可以保持，你知道的，一个囚犯向我描述他是如何把牙膏盖保持得绝对干净的，当他出狱后有个室友时，这真的很难。事实上他再也不能控制牙膏盖了。
So it kind of gives you a sense of of how intense it is to survive and then how long those coping mechanisms linger afterwards. You talk in the book, Caramette, about inmates trying a number of different things to not just be physically active and mentally active, but emotionally expressive to try and find ways to do artistic things. Can you talk about that for a moment? Prisoners do struggle to find ways to do artistic things. Can you talk about that for a moment? Prisoners do struggle to find ways to express themselves. Sometimes that's becoming really good at the law
所以这在某种程度上让你对生存是多么激烈，以及那些应对机制在之后会持续多久有了个概念。卡拉米特，你在书中谈到，囚犯们尝试了许多不同的事情，不仅要保持身体和精神上的活跃，还要在情感上具有表现力，试图寻找做艺术的事情的方法。你能谈谈那个吗？囚犯们确实在努力寻找表达自我的方法。有时这变成了精通法律——
and litigating cases, but very often it's teaching themselves to draw, sometimes teaching themselves to speak a new language, sometimes teaching themselves to sew. One of my favorite stories was a prisoner who told me that he was in isolation for a number of months and I'm not even sure how he made himself a needle. I know that he pulled threads out of the jumpsuits They're given in order to make thread and then he started tailoring His clothes so that they fit better there they're often given these very loose jumpsuits And so he would add cuffs were short in the sleeves And I think other prisoners found out about him doing this. And
并打官司，但通常是自学画画，有时是自学说一门新语言，有时是自学缝纫。我最喜欢的故事之一是一个囚犯告诉我，他在隔离区呆了好几个月，我甚至不确定他是怎么给自己做出一根针的。我知道他从发给他们的连体工装裤上扯下线来做成线，然后他开始裁剪——
in some cases, a friendly officer would pass a uniform back and forth. And he started tailoring other people's uniforms. It's kind of not that anyone is even seeing them. But it's this amazing kind of self-expression and community that they're managing to create in this place. I'm sure they're going to be people who say, look, there are lots of people in these units who really are the worst of the worst. Maybe not all of them are, but some of them probably are. Some of them probably are really violent and really dangerous, and not to be there.
他的衣服，以便它们更合身，他们经常拿到这些非常宽松的连体工装裤，所以他会加上袖口或缩短袖子。我想其他囚犯发现了他做这件事。而且——
And I'm wondering, do you ever feel that they might be people who need to be in solitary confinement? So, there are certainly people in isolation who are dangerous. One of the really important points of analysis is the length of time people are spending in isolation. The fact that people, we're not talking about weeks or months, we're talking about years and decades often, and that even people who might have been fairly scary or dangerous in their 20s are unlikely to be that way into
在某些情况下，友好的警官会把制服传来传去。他开始为其他人裁剪制服。这倒不是说甚至有人能看到它们。但这是他们在这样一个地方设法创造的一种惊人的自我表达和社区感。我确信会有人说，看，这些单元里有很多人真的是最坏中的最坏。也许并非所有人都是，但有些人可能确实是。其中一些人可能真的很暴力，真的很危险，不应该留在那里。
their 40s and 50s. And as we look at decades of these policies, we see that even some of the people who have been held up as the scariest, the system didn't control them very well while they were in it, and they're doing surprisingly well outside of isolation. So it really does call the practice into question on all different levels. So your book comes at a time when many liberals and conservatives have joined hands to call for prison reform, for one thing, keeping people in prison and keeping someone in solitary confinement is very, very expensive. Give us a sense of how expensive it is and whether these ideological pairings are triggering any change in the
我想知道，你是否曾觉得他们可能是确实需要被关进单人禁闭室的人？所以，隔离区里确实关着危险人物。分析中一个非常重要的点是人们在隔离区度过的时间长度。事实上，人们，我们讨论的不是几周或几个月，我们讨论的往往是几年和数十年，甚至那些在20岁时可能相当可怕或危险的人，在他们——
system. So, solitary confinement is astronomically expensive. In states like California, it costs about $45,000 per prisoner per year to keep someone in the general prison population, and it costs about $90,000 per prisoner per year to keep someone in isolation. So, the cost of running the facilities is really expensive because these prisoners in isolation, every need has to be met by someone working in the prison,
40多岁和50多岁时也不太可能是那样。当我们回顾几十年的这些政策时，我们看到，甚至一些被标榜为最可怕的人，当他们身处其中时，系统并没有很好地控制他们，而他们在隔离区之外却表现得惊人地好。因此，它确实在各个不同的层面上对这种做法提出了质疑。所以你的书出版之际，许多自由派和保守派携手呼吁进行监狱改革，一方面，把人关在监狱里并把人关在单人禁闭室里是非常非常昂贵的。让我们大致了解一下它有多昂贵，以及这些意识形态的结合是否正在引发系统的任何变化？
whether it's delivering mail or delivering legal documents or getting them a meal. And so that's how the costs go up. And the cost of the facilities are also expensive to build these kinds of technologically advanced facilities. And that's not even wrapped into that per-prisoner per-year cost. So I think that has been part of the reform conversation, as you suggest, that perhaps there might be a less expensive way to do this work. One other cost of isolation is that the vast majority of people, even from long-term solitary confinement, ultimately get out of prison.
因此，单人禁闭极其昂贵。在像加州这样的州，把一个人留在普通监狱人口中每年花费大约45,000美元，而把一个人关在隔离区每年花费大约45,000美元的说法有误（原文为：costs about $90,000 per prisoner per year to keep someone in isolation）。因此，运营这些设施的成本非常昂贵，因为这些处于隔离状态的囚犯，每一个需求都必须由在监狱里工作的人来满足——
It's 95 to 98 percent of all prisoners get out eventually, and that's surprisingly true of people in isolation too, and so there's the question of what are the social impacts of letting people out. And I think in combination, those economic costs and the social costs, people are beginning to think about alternatives, and that is a conversation that is cross- this political lines. And prison, as I suggested in many states, legislators are initiating reforms.
无论是送信、送法律文件还是给他们送饭。这就是成本上升的方式。而且建造这些技术先进的设施的建设成本也很昂贵。这甚至还没有被计入每名囚犯每年的成本中。所以我认为这已经是改革对话的一部分，正如你所暗示的那样，也许有一种成本较低的方法来做这项工作。隔离的另一个代价是，绝大多数人，甚至是从长期单人禁闭中出来的人，最终都会离开监狱。
Some litigation has happened, but in many states, prison officials within the system are looking at the norms changing in the critiques of this practice and initiating their own reforms, saying, what can we do to reduce our reliance on this practice? Caramette Reiter is a professor at the University of California at Irvine. She's the author of the book, 23-7, Pelican Bay Prison,
95%到98%的囚犯最终都会出去，隔离区的人也出奇地如此，因此就存在释放人们的社会影响是什么的问题。我认为结合这些经济成本和社会成本，人们开始考虑替代方案，这是一场跨越政治路线的对话。正如我在许多州所暗示的那样，监狱立法者正在发起改革。
and the rise of long-term solitary confinement. Caramette, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Maggie Penman, Jenny Schmidt, Reina Cohen, Renee Clark Clark and Chloe Connelly. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Debbie Cowan. Debbie is NPR's chief financial officer. She's an unassuming person with a razor sharp mind. She spends a lot of time thinking about how to generate the revenue to support NPR's journalism.
发生了一些诉讼，但在许多州，系统内部的监狱官员正在审视规范的变化以及对这种做法的批判，并启动他们自己的改革，询问我们能做些什么来减少对这种做法的依赖？卡拉米特·赖特是加州大学尔湾分校的教授。她是《23-7：鹈鹕湾监狱与长期单人禁闭的兴起》一书的作者。卡拉米特，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·彭曼、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、蕾妮·克拉克和克洛伊·康利制作。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们这周的无名英雄是黛比·考恩。黛比是NPR的首席财务官。她是一个谦逊的人，有着极其敏锐的头脑。她花了很多时间思考如何创造收入来支持NPR的新闻业。
Doing in-depth reporting takes time and costs money, and Debbie will be the first to tell you that you should take a moment to support your local public radio station. Thanks, Debbie. Before we go, we're currently working on a show about gender and jobs. In our rapidly changing economy,
进行深入报道需要时间并花费金钱，黛比将是第一个告诉你应该花点时间支持你当地公共广播电台的人。谢谢你，黛比。在我们离开之前，我们目前正在制作一个关于性别和工作的节目。在我们迅速变化的经济中，
a lot of blue-collar jobs are disappearing, and a lot of so-called pink-collar jobs are cropping up. If you're a man who's had to change careers, maybe leave a position at a factory and take up a new job as a home health care aid, or if you're a man who's been reluctant to make that kind of transition, we'd love to hear your story. Please call and leave us a message at 661-772-7246. That 661-778. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
许多蓝领工作正在消失，许多所谓的粉领工作正在涌现。如果你是一个不得不改变职业的男性，也许离开工厂的职位并从事一份家庭医疗护理助理的新工作，或者如果你是一个一直不愿进行这种过渡的男性，我们很想听听你的故事。请致电661-772-7246给我们留言。也就是661-778。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。